ce à présent avec vous hélène frade
bonjour hélène bonjour pauline à la une
de la presse on en parlait à l'instant
avec bastien renoul inquiétudes sur
l'état de la démocratie en afrique avec
après la démission du premier ministre
sous d'année notamment le soudan où les
généraux sont désormais seul aux
commandes outre cet exemple soudanais le
temps cite le cas du mali où le colonel
assimilés aux états cherchent à reporter
les élections prévues pour février et
celui de la guinée où le colonel mamadou
doumbouya se montre de plus en plus
floue sur les prochaines échéances
électorales
le reflet d'un recul de la démocratie
sur le continent d'après le quotidien
suisse qui fait état du sentiment de
gâchis exprimée par le spécialiste de la
région marc lavergne le soudan regrette
il était le pays du monde arabe le plus
près à la démocratie mais l'armée a
récupéré la révolution pour se
débarrasser du dictateur omar el béchir
en 2019 sans rien changer à l'état
profond l'afrique retournera-t-elle
inexorablement à la case des coups
d'état militaires s'interrogent wakat
serre a repris par courrier
international le site burkinabè accuse à
la fois la cdo la cédéao la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest et la communauté internationale
d'être responsable je cite dans une
large mesure du recul démocratique en
afrique par leur silence coupable sur
les dérives et l'incurie des dirigeants
inquiétude également face à la
multiplication ces derniers mois des
attaques contre la minorité musulmane en
inde de new yok times rapporte qu'une
centaine de d'indiennes musulmane de
premier plan des artistes des
journalistes ou encore des militantes
ont découvert le week-end dernier est
l'existence d'un site ou été divulgué
des images d'elle même sans leur
consentement un site ouvert dans la
journée de samedi avant d'être
rapidement fermée par les autorités
indiennes qui proposait de vendre ces
femmes au plus offrant ces fausses
ventes aux enchères rappelle celle
organisée en juillet dernier par un
autre site web où étaient proposés les
profils de plus de 80 musulmane indienne
décrite comme les bonnes affaires du
jour dans un cas comme dans l'autre il
ne s'agissait que de vent virtuel mais
de rabaisser il s'agissait surtout de
rabaisser ses femmes en partageant leurs
images et leurs données personnelles et
times of india condamnent ces pratiques
de cyber harcèlement et demande aux
autorités indiennes de ne pas se
contenter de fermer ces sites mais de
poursuivre réellement leur coupable ne
pas le faire non seulement risque
d'enhardir les discours de haine et
d'intimidation dans le monde réel comme
dans le monde virtuel je cite mais
également de nuire à l'image de l'inde
de plus en plus mise en cause pour son
traitement des minorités met en garde le
journal que l'inde devienne l'un de ces
pays où le majorit harris met une force
brute au dessus des lois ce serait une
véritable tragédie on ne se quittent pas
là dessus dans un registre nettement
moins dramatique pauline la gardienne
fait état d'une polémique en italie sur
l'installation d'une statue d'elena
cornaz hop iscopia c'est la première
femme au monde à avoir obtenu un
doctorat l'installation sa statue parmi
les soixante dix autres statues
représentant toutes sans exception des
personnalités masculines qui ornent
actuellement prato della valle c'est la
plus grande place d'italie cette place
qui se trouve à pablo à padoue et dédié
au personnage historique originaire de
cette ville où liée à son histoire
héléna morna rock puisque pia ayant
obtenu son doctorat en philosophie à
l'université de padoue en 1678 a priori
il ne devra pas y avoir de problème sauf
que plusieurs historiens celle axa scor
se sont opposés à cette idée pour tout
un tas de raisons l'un expliquant par
exemple qu'une nouvelle statue d'elena
cornaro petit skopia détournerait le
public de celles qui existent déjà à
l'université de padoue un autre estimant
qu'il serait préférable de laisser vide
tel quel les deux emplacements vides
donc de cette place pour symboliser les
statuts détruite par les troupes de
napoléon
des arguments qui peuvent laisser
songeur mais est certainement de très
bonne foi évidemment merci beaucoup
allen c'était la revue de presse on se
retrouve très vite sur l'antenne de
france vannes
[Musique]